y nos preguntan cuál es una estimación
razonable para el límite de eje x cuando
x se aproxima a 3 y bueno aquí de color
azul tenemos la gráfica de igual a g de
x y queremos saber cuál es el límite
conforme x se aproxima a 3 así que esto
es x igual a 3 entonces lo que
necesitamos hacer es pensar en cuál es
el límite de esta función conforme nos
aproximamos desde la izquierda y también
vamos a pensar en cuál es el límite de
esta función cual parece ser al observar
la gráfica conforme nos aproximamos a
este valor desde la derecha y bueno
parece ser que nos aproximamos al mismo
valor entonces esa sería una estimación
razonable para el límite y la razón por
la que nos piden una estimación
razonable es porque lo haremos
intuitivamente y no tenemos mucha
información sobre la gráfica pero
analizando la gráfica podemos llegar a
una estimación razonable entonces pausa
el vídeo y vean si pueden resolver esto
ustedes solos ok
veamos esto en dos partes vamos a pensar
en el límite cuando x se aproxima a 3
desde la izquierda
miren si nos aproximamos a x igual a 3
desde la izquierda podemos ver a simple
vista que nuestra gráfica se acerca al
valor 4 entonces desde el lado izquierdo
parece ser que nos aproximamos a 4 lo
escribiré de esta forma 7 x se aproxima
a cuatro cuando x se aproxima a 3 desde
la izquierda y ahora analicemos esto
desde la derecha
conforme x se aproxima a 3 desde la
derecha a que se aproxima gx bueno
parece que gdx se aproxima a menos 3
conforme x se aproxima a 3 desde la
derecha así que podemos decir que gdx se
aproxima a menos tres cuando x se
aproxima a 3
de la derecha entonces miren aquí
tenemos dos valores diferentes cuando
nos acercamos desde la derecha y desde
la izquierda desde la izquierda parece
ser que gdx se aproxima a cuatro pero
cuando nos acercamos desde la derecha
parece ser que gdx se aproxima a menos
tres y por eso es que para este límite
es razonable decir que no existe este
límite no existe
y eso lo supimos por lo que analizamos
en esta gráfica aunque una buena pista
para saber que no existe es que el valor
de x cuando tratamos de encontrar el
límite podemos ver este agujero que hay
en la gráfica porque aquí es discontinua
brinca de un valor a otro y esa es una
buena forma de saber que es muy posible
que el límite no exista aquí